THE FRESHMAN BUILDING STILL
BOARDED UP AND A CRIME SCENE.
>> Bret: THAT'S TOUGH.
PHIL KEATING, THANKS.
PRESSURE ON CONGRESS TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT GUNS AND SCHOOL
SAFETY AFTER ITS TEN DAY
VACATION.
ONE OF THE FIRST OPTIONS:
TOUGHER BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THE CALENDAR IS ALWAYS IS
CHOCK-FULL.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL FILLS
US IN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE WANTS
ACTION ON GUN CONTROL.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS PLANNING A
MEETING FOR WEDNESDAY WITH
BIPARTISAN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
>> SHIFTING TO A MEASURE BY JOHN
CORNYN AND CHRIS MURPHY TO
TIGHTEN UP THE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM.
RECORDS FROM BUYING FIREARMS.
THEY WANT TO SEE WHAT THE SENATE
IS CAPABLE OF PASSING BUT
PREDICTED THAT CONGRESS WILL
ACT.
>> WE TOOK ACTION LAST YEAR BUT
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO ANY MORE
LEGISLATION.
>> THE MEASURE WAS ATTACHED TO A
CONCEALED CARRY PROVISION FOR
NEW JERSEY REPUBLICAN COMMERCE
MEN LANCE HAS WRITTEN PAUL RYAN
ASKING TO BRING UP THE
BACKGROUND CHECK ASPECT.
HOUSE MAJORITY WHIP, A VICTIM OF
GUN VIOLENCE, FOCUSED ON
PARKLAND ATTACK.
>> WHY DID THE BREAKDOWNS OCCUR?
LET'S FOCUS ON ADDRESSING THE
PROBLEMS AND MENTAL HEALTH WE
HAVE STARTED TO DEAL WITH IN
CONGRESS.
LET'S CLOSE LOOPHOLES.
LET'S FIGURE OUT WHAT WENT WRONG
WITH GOVERNMENT BEFORE PEOPLE
START TO TALK ABOUT TAKING AWAY
THE RIGHT TO LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
>> THERE'S A DEADLINE AFFECTING
THE SO-CALLED DREAMERS.
>> CONTINUING COURT PROTECTION,
1,000 YOUNG PEOPLE WILL BE
SUBJECT TO DEPORTATION.
THEY INCLUDE 900 WHO HAVE
VOLUNTEERED TO SERVE IN THE
MILITARY.
>> TODAY AFTER THE SUPREME COURT
REJECTED THE REQUEST TO DECIDE
WHETHER ENDING DACA COULD BE
ENFORCED, PRESIDENT TRUMP NOTED
THAT THE PROGRAM IS WORKING ITS
WAY THROUGH THE COURTS AND MADE
A BROADER POINT TO THE NATION'S
GOVERNORS.
>> WE HAVE TO GET IMMIGRATION
LAWS THAT ALLOW US TO DO WHAT WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO.
THEY ARE SO SOFT.
NO COUNTRY IN THE WORLD HAS
SO SOFT.